-Oh, good.
Oh, boy. Oh, boy.
-Really? Come on.
-This is amazing.
-Oh, it is amazing.
I'm so happy you're here!
-I'm so happy to be here.
-You came all the way
from Madrid
-Yeah.
-to see us?
-Thank you so much.
-Why not?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
This is your first ever
talk show,
late night talk show appearance?
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-I'm so honored.
-Can you believe this,
my first talk show here
with Jimmy Fallon,
Nicole Kidman, too, you know?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. It's just us talking.
-Yeah.
-Well, I have to talk about it.
Congrats on the success --
"Money Heist."
-Thank you.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's been crazy.
Thank you, guys.
-When did you realize
that it was just giant?
-Well, I remember I was
in Uruguay.
I was with my parents-in-law
and my boyfriend
and we were celebrating
the New Year's Eve.
-Yeah.
-And it was crazy
because I went to this party
and it was crowded
and, all of a sudden --
People didn't recognize me there
before, you know?
-yeah, sure.
-So, all of a sudden,
everybody was coming
up to me like --
"Tokio, Tokio, eres una diosa.
Eres una --"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like --
-Wow! "Something changed."
-"What's going on here?
This is crazy."
-"Something changed," yeah.
-Yeah.
And I remember I --
Because my brain wasn't able
to understand what was going on,
I remember I said
to my boyfriend,
"What a coincidence
that all the people
who watch 'Money Heist' are here
in this party," you know?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What are the odds?
Everyone who watches the show
are at this party.
-Yeah, it's like,
"This is crazy."
I remember I had one million
followers in Instagram.
-Yeah.
-And, the day after,
I had two million
and I was like,
"Come on. This is not working.
[ Laughter ]
Anything is working.
What's going on?"
You know?
It was crazy. Crazy.
-"How is this possible?"
Doubled from a million
to two million.
Who have you been most surprised
to hear is a fan of yours?
-Wow.
I would say Madonna.
-Oh!
[ Audience oohs ]
-Really?! Talk to me.
-I know.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
"No big deal."
-You know, celebrities...
-Yeah, me and Madonna, yeah.
-Celebrities, you know.
-Celebrity, yeah.
-How did you find out
Madonna was a fan?
-So, this is a great story.
I was in L.A. and I was
traveling to --
I was going back to Madrid
and there was this layover
in London.
So, when I got on the plane,
I went to the bathroom
and, when I was going back
to my seat, I saw Madonna.
[ Laughter ]
And it was like --
"What?!
Is that Madonna?"
-Yeah.
-And I saw how Madonna
turned back to me
and she made this eye contact
with me.
[ Laughter ]
And, all of a sudden, I saw
how she came directly to me.
-She did?
-Keeping the eye contact,
[ Laughter ]
you know?
And then, she came to my seat.
Like I don't know how to do it
because I'm wearing this dress,
but...
-Oh, sorry.
[ Laughter ]
-...she started
putting on her shoes
like this in my seat.
[ Laughter ]
Her sneakers, you know.
-In your seat, on your lap?
-In my seat.
Then she was like, "Hey!
Hi!"
And I was like --
[ Mumbles ]
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, you go, "Wait.
What's going on?"
-And she said, "I'm sorry.
I just wanted to say
I'm a huge fan of you.
I love 'Money Heist'
and Tokio is
my favorite character.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Are you kidding me?
[ Rimshot ]
Madonna says that to you?
-Yeah.
-That's a win.
-Yeah, I know.
-That's a win right there.
-And I tried so hard
to say something,
but I couldn't.
No.
[ Laughter ]
Not even a word.
And I was like --
[ Sputtering ]
[ Laughter ]
-Nothing's coming out.
-And she was like,
"Are you okay?
[ Laughter ]
Are you okay?"
-Yeah.
And then she said,
"Do you know who I am?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
What?!
-No, that was embarrassing.
And I was like,
all of a sudden, I --
-Came out.
-I could talk, you know?
And I said,
"Of course I know who you are.
You're [bleep] Madonna."
-Okay, alright.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Alright.
Very loudly.
Okay, alright, yes.
-Know what I mean?
-Yes, I do.
-And then she was like, "Okay."
She gave me her phone.
-What?
-And she said,
"Write your phone.
Give me your phone,"
and she left.
So, all of a sudden, I was
with Madonna's phone in my hand
and she left.
-This is Madonna's phone,
You're entering your contact
in Madonna's phone.
-And then I left and I received
this message from Madonna.
-A text message from Madonna?
-Yeah. And she said,
"Darling, you forgot
your passport in your seat.
The stewardess has it."
[ Laughter and ohs ]
-So I could fly back home
because of Madonna.
Is that unbelievable?
-See? That's exactly
what she does.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's a great story.
-That's amazing.
-We love you, Madonna.
Of course, she does something
cool like that.
-She's amazing.
-Get ready. You're going
to love this show.
-Thank you.
-Here's Ursula Corberó
in the final season
of "Money Heist."
Take a look.
[ Laughs ]
Yeah! Úrsula Corberó, everybody!
[ Cheering and applause ]
The final season
of "Money Heist"
is streaming now on Netflix.